je les dix salles de spectacles cinéma
et musées n'ouvriront finalement pas
demain comme c'était pourtant envisagée
dans la stratégie de déconfinement
édictées par emmanuel macron il ya
quelques semaines en cause une
circulation trop importante du virus
mais pour les professionnels de ces
secteurs cette fermeture reste
incompréhensible
on en parle avec notre invité l ndiago
bonsoir bonsoir vous êtes la directrice
des musées et châteaux de tours c'est
une professionnelle en colère que
j'accueille sur le plateau une colère
que vous avez faits dont vous avez fait
part au ministère de la culture via un
courrier adressé au ministère par
l'association des musées de la région
centre soixante et une structure doivent
rester fermés en quoi cette décision est
incompréhensible pour vous est-ce que
les musées quand ils sont fréquentés de
ne sont pas des lieux où le virus
pourrait circuler
de toute façon les musées sont des lieux
où circule le virus mais comme les
grands magasins c'est à dire quand on
grogne ni plus ni moins de risque
d'aller au musée que finale ermont
d'aller faire ses courses
dans n'importe quelle structure et je
dirais même qu'il ya moins de risque de
venir dans un musée visité une
exposition puisque par définition dans
un musée nous avons des protocoles de
sanitaires qui sont très stricts des
jauges également qu'ils sont très basses
par rapport à nos jauge habituelle est
par définition ne touche pas les
collections dans un musée vous demandez
quoi aujourd'hui une date d'ouverture
précise en fait voilà ce que ce que l'on
souhaite c'est vraiment être sûr de
notre réouverture parce que finalement
ce qui devient très problématique au
quotidien pour les équipes c'est d'être
systématiquement dans la tente est dans
une espèce d'anxiété qui consiste à
construire et déconstruire des
programmations de l'action culturelle
élevé d'explosion était alors voilà par
exemple le centenaire d'olivier debré
donc devait ouvrir vendredi prochain on
espère pouvoir l'ouvrir le 7 janvier
si c'est plus tard ça veut dire qu'il
faut qu'on demande à nos prêteurs de
repousser les prêts qu'on réorganise
toute notre action culturelle et
évidemment ça a un coût pour la
collectivité pour l'établissement qui
sera de toute façon impacter sur l'année
prochaine donc c'est aussi toutes ses
conséquences qui deviennent un peu
alarmante en cas de de confinement et au
confinement régulier si vous vous rires
amusés et sécurisé pourquoi on ne vous
laisse pas le droit d'ouvrir est-ce que
vous avez un semblant d'explication
alors j'imagine que c'est finalement sur
une vision assez globale du problème de
se dire on couvre le commerce et des
commerces puisque il ya une urgence
économique et finalement de se dire va
les musées la culture il ya moins
d'impact économique
or là c'est aussi une vision à court
terme puisque finalement nous mêmes nous
sommes producteurs d'économie à la fois
de manière directe et indirecte puisque
nous avons des prestataires nous avons
des vacataires par exemple la tour on
emploie des vacataires étudiants pour la
surveillance et la médiation c'est des
jeunes actuellement qui n'ont plus de
travail donc il ya aussi un impact
économique direct
et puis à plus long terme tout ce qu'on
produit tout ce qu'on génère c'est du
tourisme ces deux
de la recette indirects et ça c'est
vraiment non négligeable sur une
économie locale
on envisage dès à présent on parle d'une
troisième vague est ce que vous craignez
de rester fermés comme lors de cette
deuxième pendant la troisième vague est
tout à fait de toute façon on n'est pas
à l'abri de dents dans des confinement
et d'un confinement
ensuite ce qui va évidemment encore plus
impacté nos programmations notre
activité et on va tous se retrouver
finalement un petit peu comme le
spectacle vivant dans un goulot
d'étranglement où on ne pourra plus
reporter certains projets et donc il y
aura des coûts qui seront perdus pour la
collectivité des artistes qu'on pourra
pas réengagé enfin voilà donc il ya
vraiment quelque chose d'assez enfin
finalement une espèce de spirale d'un
cercle un peu vicieux qui commence à
s'installer parce que la culture est
sacrifiée en ce moment c'est ce que vous
diriez mais c'est vrai que c'est quand
même un sentiment que de plus en plus
les professionnels ont d'être quand même
abandonnées de d'être d'avoir une
société qui se réduit à travailler
consommer et de ne plus avoir cette
ouverture 7
c'est un peu cet air frais à aller faire
autre chose
effectivement visiter une exposition
aller au théâtre aller au cinéma c'est
aussi des moments pour s'ouvrir et
sortir de cette angoisse cette anxiété
ce qui nous entoure on entend beaucoup
les professionnels de la culture comme
vous exprimer cette colère est ce que
vous pensez qu'il pourrait y avoir un
impact pour qu'on vous donne juste avant
une date un moment ou un autre ont
vraiment on espère effectivement que la
mobilisation permettent de faire prendre
conscience au gouvernement qu'il faut
qu'on ait une véritable
visibilité sur les prochains mois pour
finalement ne pas non plus
ce s'épuiser à être constamment dans
dans des problématiques de ré ouverture
et de fermeture qui impacte tout le
champ d'activité